an uncertain future Supernatural
suggestions and a 40-year long story arc
coming to a close there's a lot to
unpack and Halloween ends including the
way it actually ends at the start of
Halloween ends Jamie Lee Curtis's Lori
Strode is doing her best to move on with
her life no longer hidden away from the
world Laurie starts writing a book about
her experiences with Michael Myers while
living with her granddaughter Allison
played by Andy matichick however Lori
still senses there's Darkness infecting
Haddonfield Illinois before long all of
her old fear paranoia and Readiness to
fight start to re-emerge but by the end
of the film Lori seems to have finally
been able to put those things to rest at
least for the most part she's killed her
Boogeyman destroyed his body and gone
back to work on her book she even lets
Alison leave Haddonfield to start a new
life Halloween ends suggests that
haddonfield's most determined Survivor
has undergone a rebirth of sorts but
that she's still a little haunted
serving as a reminder that Lori will
never stop looking over her shoulder
it's revealed that Lori has Michael's
mask which is sitting on a table in her
office
Allison Nelson grew up with the paranoid
Specter of her grandmother looming over
her while Lori tried her best to offer
love and protection it's clear that
Allison's view of the world has been
informed by her upbringing like Lori
Allison is trying to move on from the
darkness of haddonfield's past but she
now has her own inner Darkness to
contend with not only is Alison
wrestling with the deaths of her parents
at Michael's hands in Halloween and
Halloween kills she's also forced to
overcome a romantic relationship with
Corey Cunningham the new local Boogeyman
at first Alison is unwilling to believe
her grandmother's claim that she's
heading down a very dark path with Corey
however she ultimately realizes that
Lori was right to warn her and a brand
new serial killer was hiding in plain
sight but the solution when all the
fighting is over and both Michael and
Corey are dead isn't to keep hiding or
to lock herself away in Haddonfield like
her grandmother once did instead Alison
leaves her hometown behind to start
fresh somewhere else while she seems
hopeful it's clear that Alison is all
too aware of the true evils of the world
and well equipped to take care of
herself
following the losses at the end of
Halloween kills the pool of Michael
Myers survivors has shrunk considerably
one major player who stuck around for
Halloween ends alongside Lori and
Allison is Lindsay Wallace played by
Kyle Richards of course in 1978's
Halloween Lindsay was Annie brackett's
babysitting charge her babysitter Andy
bracket was executed that night Lindsay
managed to hide from Michael in
Halloween kills and survive four years
later Lindsay seems to have a pretty
good life she's running a local bar
throwing festive Halloween parties for
the locals and even growing closer to
Lori and Ellison but when violence
starts to creep back into Haddonfield
Lindsay is swept up in the Michael Myers
stereo once again however Richard's
character doesn't play as big a part in
Halloween ends and she doesn't face the
same level of violence that follows
Laurie and Allison by the end of the
film Lindsay stands as one of only a
handful of survivors of the original
1978 Massacre alongside Lori as far as
we can tell it seems like she'll remain
in Haddonfield field where she'll be an
important part of the town's future
particularly since she knows how to move
on from tragedy will Patton's Deputy
Frank Hawkins was one of the men who
arrested Michael Myers on Halloween
night in 1978. in Halloween kills we
learned that Frank and Lori once had a
strong flirtation that could have turned
into something more if they weren't both
so damaged and reluctant I always liked
you in Halloween ends Frank and Lori run
into each other in a grocery store and
it seems like it might finally be the
right time to pick up where they left
off at the end of the film following
Lori's gruesome battle with Michael
Myers Frank stops by Lori's House the
pairs sit together on her front steps
and it suggested that Laurie might
finally be ready to take a chance on
romance now that her boogeyman is behind
her while it's unclear whether or not
they'll actually get together viewers
are left with a sense of hope for a
potential shared future
Halloween ends is based around the story
of Corey Cunningham a local Haddonfield
kid whose world was shattered on
Halloween night in 2019. Corey was
responsible for the death of a child he
was babysitting making him a town Pariah
and leaving him with a lifetime of Lost
Dreams however Corey's guilt is
eventually eclipsed by his desire to
understand his own darkness and go
deeper into it something he's able to do
when he crosses paths with Michael Myers
in a sewer Dream by the end of the film
Corey has essentially proclaimed himself
the new Haddonfield Boogeyman he even
goes so far as to steal and wear
Michael's mask in an attempt to get
revenge on all the people who have
wronged him of course Lori is smarter
than Corey and manages to stop him in
his tracks after leaving a path of
bodies in his wake Corey becomes
integral to haddonfield's tragic Legacy
but for now at least it's unclear
whether he is a new Boogeyman or just a
footnote in the story of Michael Myers
Haddonfield is a town that has been
rocked by an absurd amount of tragedy
over the course of 40 years and it's
taken a toll even with Michael Myers
gone the town continues to suffer what
feels like an ongoing series of
accidents deaths suicide and other
tragedies there's a darkness in
Haddonfield which Lori Witnesses even
when she does something as benign as
going to the grocery store it's also
revealed that some of Michael's
survivors and their families blame her
for provoking the killer to more
violence Michael's death at the end of
the film and the ceremonial crushing of
his body at the junkyard temporarily
puts an end to this Darkness but viewers
are left with more questions about the
future of Haddonfield such as will the
town ever truly be free of the Specter
of evil will more people like Corey
Cunningham rise up to take Michael's
place or as haddenfield finally able to
live in a world of Safety and Security
once again it's an understatement to say
that the town's been through a lot and
the road to any sort of recovery is
bound to be very long
though Michael has seemingly died in
other Halloween films none of them quite
matched the death he was given in
Halloween ends after being pinned to a
table by Lori and Allison Michael was
bled to death through several cuts to
key arteries along his body but as
Allison astutely noted Michael Myers
still wasn't quite dead enough with the
support of local law enforcement and
much of the Town Lori and Allison took
Michael's body to the nearby junkyard
there they placed him in a grinder and
crushed him to pieces while his body has
destroyed everyone is left wondering
whether Michael Myers can ever really be
killed in Halloween kills Lori theorized
that Michael Myers seemed to possess a
superhuman ability when it came to
killing and cheating death the more he
kills the more he transcends into
something else Halloween ends seemingly
demonstrates Lori's theory in one
particular scene Michael kills Allison's
ex-boyfriend and his body seems to
almost immediately recover some of its
strengths but were never told where
Michael's immense strength comes from or
whether someone else can actually access
it while Corey seems to believe that he
can take over from Michael and perhaps
acquire some of that power his fast
demise suggests otherwise Michael Myers
is dead the ending of Halloween ends
makes that clear by showing us his
corpse then crushing that corpse in a
brutal piece of junkyard Machinery the
film is intent on making sure that this
Michael Myers timeline is complete and
that Lori strode's fighting Days Are
Over except not all of Michael is really
gone at least not the version of Michael
that emerged when he pulled on his mask
and became the shape the final shot of
the film reveals that the mask battered
and burned is still present in Lori's
house as a dark souvenir of her Victory
Lori probably wanted to keep the
horrifying object because she didn't
want collectors or copycats to get their
hands on it it's also worth noting that
she could have destroyed the mask but
she didn't Lori's decision to save the a
mask raises a number of intriguing
questions for one we're left wondering
if the mask might hold power over Lori
now that it's in her possession Michael
never wanted to remove the mask and he
would stop whatever he was doing to pull
it back down if someone tried to take it
from him plus Michael's apparent
Transcendent abilities while wearing the
mask suggests that it's more than just a
face covering if so Lori may have made a
terrible mistake in keeping the mask as
a trophy Haddonfield is a relatively
small town that's been rocked by some
serious tragedies Through The Years in
fact Corey Cunningham is the second
major mass murderer to come out of the
town in 40 years and his Killing Spree
is inextricably linked to the
devastation caused by Michael Myers in
2018's Halloween a pair of True Crime
podcasters came to town with a specific
focus on the town's 1978 tragedy proving
that there was widespread interest in
the case and in Halloween ends Lori
Strode completes her Memoir about
Michael Myers and it seems likely that
the book will throw Haddonfield into the
national Spotlight once again as
haddenfield looks to a future without
the serial killer will Lori Embark upon
a book tour to promote her work will the
town's various True Crime stops become
tourist destinations basically following
Corey's murder spree and the death of
Michael Myers haddonfield's profile is
on the rise even if the trilogy has come
to an end
Halloween ends represents an interesting
Benchmark in the history of the
Halloween franchise it's not the first
film that has attempted to kill off
Michael Myers for instance Michael and
Dr Sam Loomis were blown to Smithereens
in 1981's Halloween 2 and they both
managed to return in the fourth film in
1998 Lori decapitated Michael with a
fire ax in Halloween H2O however this
version of events was retconned in
2002's follow-up Halloween resurrection
Michael's deaths didn't seem as final
and definitive in those earlier films as
the one in Halloween ends but may he
never
have a rest in peace whether Michael's
dead or not fans clearly still have an
appetite for the Halloween series but as
for where the franchise might go next is
currently unclear while Jamie Lee Curtis
seems to be well and truly done with
playing Lori Strode there's a
possibility that the series could be
rebooted in the future by a different
Studio blumhouse no longer has the
rights to the franchise having agreed to
deliver only three films but producer
Jason Blum and original Creator John
Carpenter have both suggested that as
long as Halloween films make money
someone will want to make more of them
Halloween could also live on without
Michael 1982's Halloween 3 season of The
Witch which doesn't feature the serial
killer has developed a cult following in
the years since its release in fact some
fans have even wondered if new films in
the franchise could actually revisit the
Season of the Witch timeline or take
some other radically new approach
regardless of what happens next it's
clear that the Halloween franchise is
never really over as Michael buyers
always comes back